so I want to start with on camera saying
uh how much I love the movie and
congrats thank you so much appreciate
that uh so one of the things I noticed
uh I I generally don't watch a lot of
reaction videos but I watched a reaction
video yesterday for the trailer or some
DMS dungeon the dragon's DMS that had
actually watched the trailer and were
breaking it down and I learned a lot
that I did not realize how many things
that you guys put in the movie that the
actual stuff from Dungeons and Dragons
so can you sort of talk about the fact
that you guys really did load this movie
up with stuff that players are gonna
know yeah well it was crucial to us to
have a film that worked for fans and
non-fans alike that said if you are a
fan and you do know the lore it we we
loaded it with as much of the actual
details from DND as we possibly could we
had a consultant Ashley Alexander from
E1 entertainment who uh is a huge
dungeon said is that a thing
and she she made sure to sort of guide
us in in you know keeping those details
as specific and uh authentic as possible
in a way it made our jobs easier because
there's so much to draw from you know
there's literally dozens of books filled
with creatures and all kinds of cool
stuff and so we didn't have to actually
come up with it we just had to figure
out how best to utilize it and there's
also a really fun Loop of like if
something exists in the lore but there's
not art to support it it's only existed
in like the written text we would then
go to the Wizards and Ashley would talk
to the Wizards and all of a sudden we
would get artwork come down it would be
like well this is the Fanfare for this
faction and this is the Fanfare for this
thing and all of a sudden you have all
this new stuff to work with the the
pressures are kind of remember talking
about the owl bear and we decided to
make it a more snowy owl look and there
hadn't really been that it was more of a
grizzly bear before so yeah and some of
the flags and stuff you know like the
Neverwinter Flags it was a really cool
process and every scene has something in
it that's from directly from the Lord
that's right I have like a two minutes
left and I'm thinking about how many
questions I have and I'm like oh
this is ridiculous
um one of the things I love is how you
guys balance the humor with the action
and both the humor it's very funny and
the action is very well staged uh for
the three of you what are you actually
most looking forward to with audiences
like to see the movie what are you just
really excited for them uh to see for me
personally as much as I love seeing the
reactions to the action and humor uh
it's the heartfelt moments that bring a
tear to the audience's eye that to me is
is the most gratifying because I don't
think a lot of people go into a film
called Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves and expect to to feel something
and cry and that to me is like really
nice and I'm a laugh or so I'll take
those laughs I love when they when they
laugh at the stuff I mean you there's a
moment
um in watching a movie with a crowd
where you know you have them and when
that comes fairly early in our
screenings uh it's a thrill because then
they'll follow you on the journey and I
think there's uh there's just moments
where
I we always thought they were gonna work
and people really were unsure if they
were gonna work and people in the early
screening process would be like we think
you guys should cut this moment out
we're not sure that moment works and we
watch it now with a crowd and the those
little moments that are really subtle
the crowds are eating up and uh it's
really gratifying to be like oh we we
thought that was going to be a moment
for people and it is it's like the
littlest things like Simon banging his
head on a wall in the back of a saying
it's like a fuddy laugh at that the
screening at South by and that's cool
like that's like such a detail huh my
last question for you because I haven't
gotten the wrap-up signal yet obviously
bfx is always a challenge with the the
whole movie rides on VFX and I know the
the state of the VFX industry which shot
ended up being the one that you guys had
to send back or tweak or work on because
it just was a really tough one to pull
up probably the the latter half of the
Doric Chase Warner with the deer the ax
beaks all of that was very hard to get
right to get the lighting integration
right to um you know get the animation
believable we still would love to have
had a couple more months on it but they
pulled they took it away from us yeah we
spent 10 extra weeks on that shot than
we were planning
um and uh it was uh it was a real
collaboration with the vendors and look
the the VFX industry yeah it's very
It's Tricky right now there's so many
big movies everyone's using effects it's
fraught it's fraught and and these
people work insane outward and they and
they and they're and they're such hard
workers and artists and they don't get
enough credit so I'd like to say on this
program that uh I really do appreciate
and acknowledge the incredibly hard work
that needs the effects are to do uh that
and and they're working behind the
curtain behind the scenes where people
don't often give them their own you know
acknowledgment and the fact that they
were like listen we aren't happy with
the shot either and we're gonna we're
gonna dig down and keep going and how
much time can you give us was incredible
I mean they really agree went to the mat
for us and you know I think it's it's a
cool shot but it was hard it was it was
really hard freaking hard yeah I gotta
rap with you guys I'll just say I'll see
you tonight I have way more questions
can't wait to talk to you again thanks a
lot see you tonight thanks